yes this video is for you i'm talking to
you right there the person who just
clicked on it you're in the right spot
whether this is the very first video of
mine that you've ever clicked on or
whether you have watched every single
one of my videos
you are a part of this a part of what
you may ask we just hit 10 000
subscribers and i have you guys to thank
for it so as a way to say thank you and
give back to you guys for all the love
and support you've sewn
soon
it's time for a subscriber q a you guys
ask some weird questions also special
announcement at the end of the video and
it is only made possible because of the
fact that we hit 10 000 subs people of
the internet retroback and tour here i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and today is all about
your questions when i look through all
the ones that we got i found that they
really fell into one of four different
categories so i broke them down into
personal harry potter hogwarts legacy
and gaming so if you're looking to skip
to any one of those sections i'll have
little bookmarks down below bookmarks
are they called bookmarks timestamps
whatever you can click down below and
jump to anywhere you want in the video
and if your question didn't get asked
don't worry we'll do this again when we
hit 100k microconsole asks how much
longer do you plan on making videos is
it a full-time job or more of a hobby
for you so two questions there i'll
start with the second part first it is
not a full-time job i actually work
full-time at my local library so i guess
technically it is a hobby the channel is
monetized now so i do make a little bit
of extra money each month but it's
certainly nowhere near enough to sustain
my family full time however i have never
been shy about saying that ultimately is
my goal for the channel you know i
really thought i wanted to be a twitch
streamer and i put in about two and a
half years of streaming regularly three
nights a week despite working full time
despite having a family and ultimately i
didn't get anywhere i saw a video on
youtube talking about working smarter
not harder and it really helped to
change my whole perspective i shifted my
mindset from a me mindset focusing on
myself to asking why would anyone care
about watching me on twitch and when
you're talking about youtube when you're
talking about twitch you're asking for
something that in my opinion is far more
valuable than money you're asking for
someone's time and for me to have any
kind of success at all with this whole
content creation thing i had to make it
not about me but about you guys the
viewers so i would absolutely love for
one day for this to be turned into
something full time and that is
certainly the goal that i am working
toward now for the first part of the
question though how much longer do i
plan on making videos
honestly i don't see myself stopping
anytime soon absolutely love making
videos if anything i may change the way
i make videos i may try to get more help
one day on people editing things like
that maybe different types of videos but
in terms of just completely stopping
making videos i can't see that ever
happening at least not for the
foreseeable future mr e wants to know do
you have a pet why yes yes i do
this is my little girl luna my wife and
i like to say she is our firstborn
because she was the first baby before we
had our two sons but most of the time
when you guys hear me on a video
recording or you see me like this
talking directly to the camera she is
usually sitting like right behind me on
the floor she has a bed over there in
the corner which
you know dogs sometimes they love the
bed sometimes they don't she's in there
about 25 of the time most of the time
though she's just right here in the
floor right behind me and did i say her
name was luna i bet you guys could guess
why right you guys can guess why all
right thank you luna you can go back
favorite ips aside from harry potter oh
i love this question like honestly i
could talk all day so i'm gonna try to
narrow this down let's just say top five
so harry potter of course we already
talked about that one
i would say legend of zelda
metroid
the matrix
lord of the rings and
avatar the last airbender dustin wants
to know what keeps you going what's your
drive this is a deep question it's
actually really simple for me to answer
because it's honestly been my drive for
a very long time it comes down to two
major things number one my faith number
two my family you see when i was growing
up i had such a great support system
around me look my family wasn't perfect
but i knew
all the way through growing up that i
had a family that loved me that i had a
family that cared for me i also moved
around a lot and never really had
trouble making friends and then when i
got older when i got into college and
then when i got out of college and
started spending a lot more time online
on message boards playing video games
with people from across the world i
really just started to understand how
incredibly blessed how incredibly
fortunate i was to have all of those
things and the fact that there are so
many people out there hurting every day
longing for connection longing for
relationship longing to feel like they
belong to something that is one of the
biggest reasons that i started this
youtube channel and continue to do this
channel is i want people to feel like
they belong here i want people to feel
like they they have a place where they
have someone who yeah maybe we're
talking through a computer screen maybe
i read your comment and we never meet
face to face but that is still a genuine
human connection and oh man it just gets
me fired up i mean it's just so
incredibly amazing we're celebrating 10
000 subs but i looked at my stats and
our channel is over 1.7
million
views in total i mean that's across the
whole channel which
a lot of people have way more than that
but just think about the impact that
that has on other people i have touched
1.7 million times i've had a chance now
it's gonna be the same people a lot of
those times but still i have had that
chance to impact someone for the
positive and honestly spreading that
love and spreading that goodness to
other people is really one of the main
reasons for this channel and then my
family is also a huge part of everything
i do they don't really appear on the
channel a lot in fact i'm not sure if
they ever have my wife uh she's
certainly welcome to appear on the
channel anytime she wants to she likes
to stay out of the limelight she doesn't
want to be on camera if she ever changes
her mind though i'll be happy to
introduce you guys to her with our kids
we've actually been really really torn
about that because my son loves this
stuff like he would totally be on here
with me especially my oldest son he
would he would talk with you guys but we
really want to be very careful on how we
bring up our kids and sort of what we
expose them to until he can really have
a better understanding of what he's
actually doing when he puts himself
online like i understand by putting this
video out there
it may reach five people it may reach
five million people it may reach 50
million people there could be a bunch of
you in the comments hating on my
appearance you know
you guys don't do that though you guys
are actually great for the most part
here and i know youtube has actually
done a lot to address this like if kids
appear in your video or if it's a video
geared specifically toward kids they
actually turn the comments off for that
so just because they don't appear on
screen or actually appear on the channel
at any point doesn't mean that they
aren't a huge part of what i do now in
fact my oldest son though he did appear
at least his voice appeared in one of my
videos on animal crossing it was him
giving an island tour which still to
this day is one of my favorite videos
that i've ever done and he had an
absolute blast doing it so stuff like
that i'm a little more comfortable with
and that gives him something to look
back on one day as well
jackson wants to know
what's your favorite percent of milk
hope this doesn't disappoint you jackson
but honestly i don't even like drinking
milk unless
unless it's with something very sweet
like chocolate chip cookies brownies
it's just like you have to have a glass
of milk other than that though i don't
really just like sit down and have a
glass of milk benjamin fellow hogwarts
legacy youtuber by the way wants to know
how long did it take you to get to 10k
so
this is an interesting one i had to go
back and look at this because
if you really look at when my youtube
channel started it's something like 2013
which that is not really when i started
youtube that's just when i made a
youtube account for the first time
but when i really committed and said i i
want to do this i want to keep posting i
want to keep getting better at making
videos i want to form a community i want
to make a connection with people out
there was right around april 2020. you
can go back you can look at the videos
that i was posting then that's really
when i said okay i'm gonna do this and
then right at the very end of september
is when we hit 10k so it's right at
about 18 months so about a year and a
half and i guess
where people are at in their youtube
journey they may feel that takes a
really long time or that may seem like a
really fast amount of time i don't know
for me i'm incredibly happy with where
we're at and i know it's only going to
get even better from here mary's studio
says how many kids do you have and how
long have you been doing youtube and
what inspired you to start doing it so
we kind of touched on the youtube one
already how many kids do i have i have
two boys and there's going to be more on
the kids here in a little bit so stick
around alright time for the harry potter
questions warzone army clips asks do you
listen to hp music if yes what is your
favorite song and then kind of a very
similar question hi iq warrior which
source of hp music do you like more
games or movies so the movie music
certainly sticks out more in my mind
than the games although happy hogwarts
is just like iconic right it's very
popular one which i absolutely love i
think hedwig's theme is one of the great
iconic i mean of cinema it's one of the
great iconic scores that you'll hear and
then i feel like there is one in goblet
of fire there's something it might be
when voldemort is returning i know
goblet of fire as a film was kind of a
little all over the place but that scene
that one scene that was so important for
them to hit in the graveyard was
incredible i thought they nailed that
scene and the music is certainly a big
part of it noah wants to know is
draymond
dramainy a w or l so i know what this
means if you're not a harry potter fan
you're like what the heck's he talking
about it's a ship draco hermione
shipping the two characters do i think
they would go well together no are you
crazy if you were an animagus what
animal would you turn into i've always
loved dolphins but i would hate to be
limited just to water so i think i would
want to go with something like a falcon
or an eagle that i could fly imagine
though if you're like pettigrew and got
stuck with a rat i mean come on because
in the harry potter world you do not get
to choose remember favorite piece of
harry potter media probably a cop-out
answer to say but for me easy it's it's
the original books the original seven
books i started reading them long before
they were even thinking about making
them into movies and absolutely fell in
love from the very start they have a
special place on my bookshelf and will
always have a special place on my
bookshelf i will probably do a tier list
ranking one day of the seven books it's
honestly so hard for me to go through
and rank them if i absolutely had to
pick one today though i'm going to go
with book 7 and deathly hallows i just
thought it was an absolutely incredible
ending to a series that i obviously love
very much
spav wants to know with remasters
becoming a big thing do you think we
could see any of the harry potter games
remastered for next-gen consoles
uh i wish but i don't think so honestly
those games are so old at this point
i feel like it would be such an effort
to go back and remake them that if
they're gonna do that they might as well
just go ahead and completely remake them
from the ground up and and i don't mean
remake the exact same game i mean just
take sorcerer's stone the book take
sorcerer's stone the movie and then make
a brand new video game out of it with
today's standards because i think it
would be absolutely incredible i'm
actually working on a really big harry
potter video related to all of the games
it's probably going to be a 30 minute
plus video it's taken a lot of research
to do it but especially if you ask that
question you definitely want to stay
tuned for that video at some point i
don't know when it's going to be ready
hopefully it'll be before the end of the
year for the hogwarts legacy questions
dylan is up first and he wants to know
what are you going to do in hogwarts
legacy when you get to hogwarts i really
like this question i mean obviously
there could be things in game that it
determines you have to do when you get
there it might be fairly linear for a
while before it opens up
but i think what you really mean is when
it opens up when we have that moment
where we can go and do whatever we want
we can choose a mission we can do side
quests we can just roam the castle i
think the first thing that i will do is
to fully explore the gryffindor common
room because the common room let's think
about it it's probably going to be an
area that you return to very frequently
in the game regardless of which house
you choose so that area they really need
to nail that right from the start
because each day you wake up you're
going to wake up in the common room
you've got to make sure that it feels
right
i can't wait to see what they do there
james asks another great hogwarts legacy
question he says if hogwarts legacy has
quidditch how in depth should they go i
definitely think hogwarts legacy will
have quidditch a lot of people on my
other video keep saying well if you look
in the trailer you can see the quidditch
stadium you can see that they have
brooms i know you can see they have
rooms i know you can see other signs of
quidditch possibly being there but we
just don't have confirmation yet all
that being said i think it would be just
an incredible shock if they don't have
quidditch in the game now how in depth
should they go i think they should
totally focus on of course just the
hogwarts houses you know don't worry
about trying to do anything as big as
quidditch world cup did that almost
might be something down the road that
you could do as like a dlc pack or
something
but i think the one thing that all
quidditch games even quidditch world cup
have really struggled with is finding a
way to incorporate all the positions and
make it where you could play any
position you want and it will still be
fun i mean if you think about like an
nba game you can choose any player you
can pick any player on the court you can
actually cycle between them whereas
football is a little bit different if
you're playing
american football that is if you're
playing football you really don't want
to play as one of the offensive linemen
you want to be a wide receiver or
running back or the quarterback so
maybe they could do something like that
but i want to see something that tries
to explore all of the different
positions a little bit more in depth now
all that being said quidditch really
should be secondary i don't want them to
waste a ton of time trying to make this
incredibly
just like fleshed out quidditch game
don't be wrong i hope for it but i would
much rather than focus on making a great
story making a great side quest making a
great spell casting system all of that
to me would take precedent over
quidditch now quidditch i do think they
could make an incredible online mode
featuring quidditch
maybe even some post-launch dlc
featuring quidditch i think all that
would be great port runner here says if
you look in the mirror of arisen but it
can only show you your hogwarts desires
how does the game look like and on the
opposite what do you fear most the game
might be well port runner i'll
definitely answer your question here but
i actually already have full videos up
on both of these if you guys want to
check them out i'll link the one about
gameplay features we need to see in the
little interactive card in the top right
if you're on mobile check your
description i'll include it there and
i'll also include a link to my biggest
concerns for the game but just answering
your question here if i look at the
mirror vera said okay so we're talking
hypothetical this is deepest most
desperate desire of our heart guys so
don't get mad at me and say you're
getting your hopes up retro that's never
gonna happen because hey this is a dream
this is perfect ideal scenario so just
to try and describe this rather quickly
i would want to see a mix of something
like persona particularly how it handles
relationships and that sort of high
schooler teenage dynamic and then
something like the witcher which i think
does such a spectacular job with
storytelling with the openness of the
world with the exploration witcher does
an incredible job at all that all the
side quests you feel like side quests in
the witcher could be full-blown games of
other companies it's just incredible
what they're able to do and then to
bring all that together they gotta have
good gameplay the spell casting's gotta
be great it's gotta feel immersive it's
gotta feel powerful it's gotta feel like
you get this sense of progression as you
make your way through the game biggest
fears i would say too linear if it's
very buggy if the spell casting system
is just sort of a spamming kind of like
what we got with the later harry potter
games where they just like turned it
into a shooter which was
like what are you doing come on all
right so now we're gonna shift into the
overall gaming segment and beastly wants
to know are there any other franchises
you wish would get a huge
video game oh man so many so many
i feel like we've already gotten a
couple of solid lord of the rings games
i absolutely loved uh was it return of
the king or two towers back like on the
gamecube era i think it was two towers
actually that game was so good and of
course now we've had shadow of mordor
those are pretty good lord of the rings
games okay you didn't say i had to limit
it to one so i'm gonna give you two here
i'm gonna say avatar the last airbender
series i think would make for an
incredible video game and then two
the matrix i know they have dabbled in
that i know there have been matrix games
but again
sort of like with harry potter i don't
feel like any have really truly hit that
potential of what a matrix game could
ultimately be d wants to know what other
games are you excited about well number
one coming out this week actually
metroid dread huge fan of metroid can't
wait to play that one i'm actually going
out of town for a little bit at the end
of this week so i won't get to play it
the day it comes out but as soon as i
get back might even do some let's plays
for that one eldon ring huge fan of from
software can't wait for eldon ring think
it's going to be absolutely epic let's
see what else i'm forgetting obvious
things i know i am
god of war oh how could i forget god of
war god of war is gonna be absolutely
epic breath of the wild too
yes yes so much coming from nintendo and
playstation can't wait starlight says
what are some of your most favorite
games and why what are some of your kids
favorite games so two questions they're
my favorite games well number one my
favorite game of all time is right here
the last of us it is also
the uh artwork that you can kind of see
back here yeah right up here you can't
really tell what's in it i'll get some
b-roll so you guys can get a little bit
of a better view of that but it is a
scene from the original last of us video
game
that is my favorite game of all time
followed by metroid prime and then
number three i still think holding on is
probably the legend of zelda ocarina of
time my son i'll give you three for my
son i think number one oh man it's like
it's really like a 1a1b he absolutely
adores super mario odyssey and he adores
animal crossing new horizons he's kind
of completely stopped playing animal
crossing because i think he did
absolutely everything he could possibly
do but super mario odyssey he still goes
back even after he's found everything he
like made a completely new file and he's
doing it again like he just absolutely
adores that game so i think i would give
it a slight nod above
animal crossing and then third would be
sac boy a big adventure i actually did a
review of that here on the channel if
you're a parent or an aunt uncle and you
want to play games with kids or play
games with younger ones sackboy a big
adventure is so good and you don't have
to have a ps5 i know a lot of people are
like ah i don't have a ps5 it is on ps4
as well that game is just phenomenal
it's good but on your own but it's even
better when you're playing with
especially with a young kid he had an
absolute blast with it oh and treason
also asked favorite game of all time
here you go jackson wants to know what
game would i say is close to perfect i
think a lot of people would probably
expect me to point to the one that i
just referenced my favorite game of all
time the last of us but i'll give you a
little bit something different since
they used the word perfect there
i'm gonna kind of hang on that as my
qualifier because i'm not sure that
there are any perfect games
if i was gonna say something that is the
closest to perfect though it's probably
something like tetris i mean tetris is a
game that is just so good at what it is
right i mean to this day i mean we've
seen how many re-releases of tetris and
it's a tried and true formula it works
perfectly and it's just a great game
jessica wants to know would you ever
consider playing scary or horror games
on the channel or possibly thriller
games jessica come on didn't you see my
luigi's mansion let's plays come on
no in all seriousness i'm kind of a wimp
when it comes stuff like that i'll just
be honest with you guys i don't really
love horror games you're like hey you
just said you're a huge fan of from
software yeah i am bloodborne is one of
my favorite games of all time so i guess
if that makes me a fan of horror games
then i guess i am a fan of some horror
games i also do enjoy some of the
resident evil's resident evil 4 is one
of my favorite games ever and i haven't
played village but i i watched a lot of
people play village and i'm pretty sure
i would dig that one as well but just
that that pure solely horror i i just
don't get into that i need a little
somewhat of a little bit of action with
it as well so if it kind of falls into
that blood-borne resident evil 4 that
sort of style with a little more action
to it then i'd totally be down with
playing it on the channel yeah but
something like uh what was that game
outlast no no stuff like that
not touching it colt says aside from
playing hogwarts legacy would you ever
be open to play the marvel avengers game
that came out i would like to see you
play that especially now that the game
has gotten better and has a lot of
content to do a whole playthrough of
colt i certainly uh enjoy the marvel
universe i certainly enjoy the movies
i can't say that it's on my immediate
list of like games to play but i have
checked it out and it's something that i
would be interested in playing if i had
more time i think it's definitely
something i would dive into and probably
enjoy
i did hear a lot about how they have
improved it so maybe it's something i'll
get to at some point down the road i
can't say that it's like an immediate uh
coming up or anything like that though
if that makes sense drew says have you
heard of which brook what are your
thoughts on it yes i have seen this pop
up a couple of times and i'm
intentionally not going to look this up
because you you want to know if i've
heard of it so i'm going to try to go
solely based on my memory here
it almost looked like a little bit of a
stardew valley type game but more about
witchcraft and wizardry and learning
magic and learning spells maybe even a
little bit of like an animal crossing
element there but i really enjoy stardew
valley i love animal crossing and
obviously we're big fans of the
wizarding world so i think it's
certainly something i would give a shot
to but now that you mentioned it i need
to check up on that game because i
remember last time i looked i was like
oh man it's still so far away so maybe
it's a little bit closer to release now
ally asks do you have a console if so
what are some of your games so yes i
have been really a console guy my whole
life the pc that i'm on right now is
really my first gaming pc and it's only
in the past kind of two years or so that
i've been doing a lot more pc gaming
still though i game a lot on my consoles
right now my two main consoles are the
nintendo switch and the playstation 5.
yes i did manage to get one and my
favorite games for the switch probably
would be breath of the wild super mario
odyssey animal crossing love all three
of those and then for ps5 right now i'm
really into return all i think it's an
absolutely incredible game i was
frustrated for a while i was banging my
head against the wall but now i've
really started to settle in and i'm
absolutely loving it
okay now for your surprise in the
beginning of the video i teased that i
had something that you guys only made
possible by us hitting ten thousand
squad
subscribers
something only made possible by us
hitting 10 000 subscribers and that is
this right here if you've been around
the channel for a while you guys know
that i wear this hat a lot this is a
retro hat i designed this hat i made it
and now
you that's right you out there watching
this video right now you can get your
very own retro rack and tour hat as well
but not only that
we're gonna have shirts we're gonna have
a shirt that says just a dad who loves
games we're gonna have a mug that says
just a dad who loves games and because
we hit 10 000 subs that merch store can
actually be integrated into the youtube
channel now so it may not be live the
first day this video goes up but in the
coming days below my videos below all my
videos you guys will be able to see the
merch store right there and if you see
anything hey you want to check that out
you just click on it it'll take you
there so check out the merch store let
me know what you guys think because i am
certainly open to your feedback if
there's more shirts if there's different
styles you want to see if there's
different wording you want to see if you
don't like the text if you do like the
text honestly let me know what you think
because i designed all of them myself
it's very easy for me to go in and make
changes so i'd love to hear what you
think if i haven't made it clear enough
i want to say one more time to each and
every one of you out there
thank you this is only the beginning
we're going to do some big
big things with this channel guys i
promise you that i promise you we are
not giving up and if you are somebody
out there who is feeling lost who is
feeling alone who is feeling like you
just need someone to hang out with then
i hope i can be that person for you even
it's just for a couple of minutes each
night each evening each morning whatever
it may be don't be afraid to reach out
and say hello in the comments as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon